feel like I hear about this some in
different sectors Silicon Valley a lot
of interest in meditation you don't hear
about it a lot on Wall Street and I
wonder was where this maybe these are
just people I'm talking to but a lot of
it is go go go look at the world keep
moving it's a 24-hour clock markets are
always open there's always something you
could be doing
what do you why do you believe that
meditation is so important or what has
it done for you that you feel like has
has changed how you approach life uh in
the investment area I think that there's
a it's essential it's so helpful
because
um it's so helpful for so many reasons
first of all it gives you this
Equanimity
Equanimity the centeredness so when
stuff is coming at you fast and so on
it's like in the ninja movies you know
if you watch the ninja movies there's
this quick fighting but it and then it
seems like they go to slow motion
because for the Ninja
it's like slow motion there's a calmness
that when things come at you you have
that calmness so that you can deal with
it so it's so effective in the markets
and operating that way and it also is
good for your health and your thinking
because if you have all of that so much
you have to go into the peace and the
and the quiet and it aligns the
intellect with the emotion because there
are two parts of our brains you know
there's the
um conscious logical part of our brain
and then there's the subconscious
emotional part of our brain and that
part of our brain drives us and so by
just aligning them and getting that
Equanimity it's a great power so yes it
helped I'm a Wall Street guy I mean an
investment guy who's going to deal with
that blizzard of stuff to come in and I
just recommend it so highly